[Musique]
ce sont des affirmations sur les invités
les chéris vous me dîtes si c'est vrai
ou si c'est faux car les bleus marchant
avec des mannequins vrai ou faux bien
sûr regardez moi et dan il aurait pu y
avoir été mené avec moins de 36 s'il
s'était assis frère au tour et peut être
mannequin je te le dis tel ni karine le
marchand vous avez été mannequin et
regardez on a on a des photos que vous
avez publié vous même sur votre compte
instagram les belles familles et après
on n'a pas d'eau non c'est pas mal mais
ce sont toujours les mêmes
tu fais quoi et tu n'as pas dresser la
plus aboutie que vous trouverez un site
très mal c'est vrai qu'à lycée ont été
tes déchets qui l'a non là j'étais pas
le thé party le sauveur qu'elle était
chez gt l'agencé élite
mais c'est la divine cette corde à son
art voilà karine la divine avait pas
changé je trouve plus belle maintenant
je vous dis la vérité je préférais non
mais c'est vrai voilà je vais jouer de
la flûte traversière les deux bouts
jouer de la flûte traversière d'art
basel iii elle avait dit six premiers
mois je fais pas toutes les mêmes pneus
je vous lis dany brillant s'appelle
landais en réalité dany cohen oui oui
oui ce qu'un pseudonyme que tu as pris
des thons plus jeune âge est ce que vous
savez pourquoi il après wibree moi
j'adore cette anecdote alors si c'est si
je me rappelle bien c'est parce qu'à
chaque photo le patron du cabaret où il
a démarré le disais allez soyez brio et
la débauche peu après dany brillant
château qu'il allait monter sur scène ça
heureusement qu'il n'a pas dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour dalé du coup c'est comme à l'album
totalise ou non mais t'as bien fait mais
j'aime bien dany brillant j'aime bien
annie morrissette collège
cette année ou pas dit la vérité c'est
dur comment vous la d'orge suis allé
voir en concert
merci acte menteur pas d'âge pour moi je
suis allé voir ma tenue je suis passé
sur sa allée des sports
tout à fait moi il m'a fait un menu
danser avec moi ah ouais le savait quoi
et vous a fait danser je n'ai pas connu
du tout on vous a fait monter sur scène
mais on m'a fait des séances de ses
employés mais j'adore ça annonce je suis
fan de dany dan et on va voir
d'ailleurs d'amis pas tu chantes je
passe en rigolant rareté tellouck au fur
et à mesure et vous allez voir le danis
toujours le même regard des dettes dans
les années 80 il n'a pas voulu regarder
en 2003 en 2006 c'est le même en 2012
c'est le même arrêt en 2017 si le même à
ses longs cheveux non mais verront ça
non mais sans rigoler il ya ya ya 45 ans
qui se passe et à poser
lorenzo l'a fait il subit pas les modes
ouais il reste toujours lui même
j'aimerais m'en imposer son style pour
sa réserve lors j'ai trop vu comme brûlé
au visage a changé
non ma exactement alors karina choisi le
pseudo le marchand car son ex était guy
marchand non c'est pas ça mais pourquoi
tu as pris le marchand ma maman vrai nom
c'est me faye au curé rats c'est
vraiment un peu compliqué du burundi et
moi je voulais garder mon nom je
trouvais ça cool mais le directeur des
programmes au dernier moment avant que
ça commence l'émission avoir comme une
émission commencée en direct médias non
c'est trop compliqué donc j'ai pris le
nom de mon amoureux de l'époque avec sap
et le marchand et j'embrasse ac vient de
se faire opérer de la hanche non séparé
eh bien eh ben et on l'envoie ce marché
en cavale et laurent et de la rue dany a
composé la musique du jeu motus ans
bonos on va rappeler la musique du
nouveau tube mercy
s'ils ne l'ont pas
[Musique]
si ça m'était dany brillant qui réponde
à ça fait c'est pas à nous c'est pas
d'avis karine le marchand a animé un coq
sont sur france 2 intitulé encore plus
libre ouais ouais karine c'est vrai ou
pas bien sûr on arrivait d animal
prestigieux on a retrouvé des images
c'était en 2005 j'étais venu mais me
soulevait une baignoire
c'est à dire on m'a planté la mine un
vide je pense que notre ami ciel c'est
vraiment bon allié georges et la mort
est là mon invité m'a planté à 14h on
tournait à 18h javier limón bon je te
dis la vérité l'époque ce n'était pas
non plus débordé alors normal elle
m'appelait c'était mito je peux pas te
dire tout de suite deux minutes puisque
je dois décalé brut sert à quoi d'avoir
magal h sur france 2 bah ouais les gars
regardez la salle et kabel bw
vous verrez c'est une très bonne semaine
et rita lequel vous inquiétez pas je
pense qu'on va vous détendre ce soir je
vous propose tous d'accueillir kamel
ouali
bonsoir également cyril hanouna
vous allez bien que les deux doigts
tacler nagui ça vas y toi nagui alors tu
attends moi ça se profile très bien reçu
je te préfère comme ça des sandales
hautes en avant n'était pas du tout mon
style physiquement autant là il peut se
passer un truc contre onu
ok moi c'est pourquoi j'ai mis ce
t-shirt le sucre et le succès rambo
avait bonifié un arrêt au temps dani n'a
pas bougé en gros vous êtes en train de
dire qu'il était dégueulasse
bah oui j'ai trouvé que c'était
dégueulasse mais pas d agathe
dégueulasse non pas dégueulasse mais
n'ont négligé dégueulasse c'est à dire
dès que la cua dégueulasse mais pauvre
est pas connue je n'aurais pas tenté le
dos mais rien à voir avec l'apport non
voilà j'avais de belles valeurs
je vous écris au marché là ou quoi oui à
gerber
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
totalement des bravo merci en tout cas à
agathe merci à ceux qui ont dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas totalement dégueulasse
valérie merci à julien mecheri montagny
a écrit le titre
quand je vois tes yeux avec gilbert
montagné ça c'est une savane mais
gilbert le prend très bien oui bien sûr
j'ai ador karine le marchand était
première animatrice des maternelles sur
france 5
oui non mieux la première c'est pas la
première et la deuxième c'est maïté
daytona
on a préparé une petite compil de vos
interventions dans les mariages à
jessains carrière l'humour encore en
dessous de la ceinture
nos produits jean la maison la maison
pour garder les maternelles j'ai regardé
aussi j'adore je regardais quand c'est
karine après c'était daphné burki c'est
ça après et là et j'adore avec agathe
lecaron le quart d'heure j'adore j'adore
c'est très bien c'est tellement ça
marche très fort encore entre les
maternelles ouais parce que je suis
enceinte en ce moment c'est de voir
c'est parti mon sens at-elle dit bonjour
on va rester dans le matin si vous êtes
d'accord c'est un peu fatigué ces
derniers temps
bonjour bien mais sur le plateau des
adolescents changer de métier c'est
aussi changer de vie et c'est le cas de
sylvie bonjour sylvie réno voilà nous
touchons à sa fin
en tout cas cette émission par le
marchand
dany brillant a failli casser la gueule
à gérald dahan l'imitateur vrai vrai
faux que vous dites ou faites vous ne
remettez pas une donnée celle d'avant
j'avais mon merci dany c'est vrai cette
histoire tu l'as dit tu l'as dit dans le
labo avec sébastien folin ah bon je
regardais gueule c'est un gros web on
regarde derrière la tête de justin kg
jet j'ai rien dans quelles sont au juste
un petit saucisson et donc qui s'est
vexé et il a posé une micro il est venu
vers moi et très imposant aux puces et
il m'a dit tu peux me le refaire une
deuxième fois demande de l'intéressé je
vais faire une deuxième fois donc il
refait une deuxième fois et les sorties
était furax
et puis après on s'est revu et il m'a
dit bon j'ai réfléchi et je crois que je
vais plutôt de prendre en prennent à
partie de mes spectacles je suis sûr
qu'il a fait ça en valait la peine
premier degré c'est lui faire peur mais
c'est pour rigoler ah bien sûr gardé son
premier amour karine a vécu six mois
avec un prétendant de l'amour est dans
le pré vrai ou faux non non non je sais
tu nous as dit à la fois que jamais il
tape à l'oeil et dans les maternelles
t'avais pécho manon pas c'était une
belle émission tapé do aux-in nos devine
jobs
ah ouais c'est que c'est quoi jobs veut
plus voir dany brillant et moi on a joué
au cinéma ensemble oui oui arrive
hériter jugement n'augure était resté si
je mens tu arrêtes tu jouer son propre
rôle et moi je jouais hervé cockpit et
on a récupéré les images là tout à
l'heure vous avez dit que j'étais
dégueulasse allait être dégueulasse
c'est ça regardez la faire aller simple
j'ai un fournisseur à shenzhen
il vient de fabriquer des accessoires et
des chaussures pour une grosse marque
américaine les américains voulaient
s'impliquer dans toute l'europe seul
membre
ils n'ont pas eu les emplacements qui
vous et je ne raconterai nains qudra
sera grave
ils ont dit les mecs on arrête tout
soit trouvé avec 800 mille paire de
pompes sur les bras attention la folie
les pompes à la first class c'est quoi
la marque weight comme chez sony
[Musique]
la librairie à karine le marchand qui
sont avec nous merci d'être là nouvel
album rock'n swing ses 300 kg 2 février
et chérie oui vous avez eu un coach pour
jouer vachement bien allez on y va